[Music]
on today's show we talked to two
extraordinary women who are dealing with
boundary issues who are dealing with
grief who are dealing with the way
things should have been and the world
has turned upside down on them and they
want to know what to do next we also
take an email and it's fascinating stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo yo this is john with the dr john
dalone's show
man i'm glad you're here hope you're
doing well
i know things are so chaotic so bananas
but i'm glad you're here with us i'm
glad you're walking alongside us
glad to see your smiling face james
you're not smiling at all kelly's not
even looking at me
new zack is smiling and a really forced
fake smile like an old mills photo photo
it's good to see you man but the faux
hawk is rocking
don't come a knocking
james good to see you you too
he can't really talk back to you that
easily but he was making fun of your um
brawny paper towels shirt so
he's giving it back to you back here hey
i never know when we got to get the
chainsaws out and get to work around
here
don't don't we always like chop wood or
water or something and make flapjacks
i love flapjacks i love flapjacks with
all my h-e-r-t james listen
uh a couple weeks ago i don't know how
when these shows come out
um somebody called and they asked about
what i thought about a boss
or a business making their employees
have to get the kovitz vaccine
and um
one of the analogies i used was
i used to work somewhere and they called
me in and said hey you can't wear a suit
but not tuck your shirt in you look like
a slob you gotta tuck your shirt in if
you're gonna work here
and then i had a decision to make and so
i drew that analogy that businesses now
some of them are saying
vaccinations are on you we're gonna
offer it with like a flu shot i i went
and spoke at a at a big company this
weekend in texas and they were offering
flu shots in cove shots downstairs for
anybody who wants them
but i made the analogy that some
businesses are saying you have to have
this to work here
and dude the internets lost their
internet mind
saying there's a big difference between
putting things in your body and tucking
your shirt and this guy's an idiot
which is exactly what i said on the show
is that what you said i didn't say
you're an idiot but i said there's i
said i understand the analogy but it's
not exactly the same thing okay how is
it not the same to me it's this exact
same thing which is now number one
people of the internets
i know it's a different thing injecting
something in your body i get that
what i was trying to get was the
philosophy behind it meaning or the
principles probably a smarter way to say
that you should have your own show james
is
if your boss tells you to do a thing
then you do the thing or you don't work
there
that make sense
why is it different you think it's
different why no you're right that the
principle is the same i was just saying
tucking your shirt in is just like tuck
it in
you can untuck it when you get home
the vaccine is something that
oh you've got
thousands of people have been
researching for a year frantically
i mean it's you know what i mean it's
not different it's not the same thing
but the
overarching principle is the same of
businesses can can
private businesses can do what they want
and you can stay or not say yeah and i
also get a couple of folks um wrote in
and said
this is my career track right like all i
work for the railroad or i'm a i'm a
unionized welder and everyone not even
unionized well they're like i'm a police
officer i'm uh whatever
and
they're making all of us do it so if i
quit this job i quit the profession
and dude i get that my heart's with you
it's hard
i get that and
at the end of the day you got a choice
to make
one of the things i had a buddy reach
out and he's a um
gosh he's so brilliant he's a
extraordinary travel nurse
and um we just had it back and forth
real quick but i asked him are you gonna
end up getting this vaccine and he said
yeah i'm gonna end up doing it and my
recommendation was do it tomorrow
if you've already made up the decision
it made up your mind
uh i don't want to do this i'm not
thinking about it i don't like being
even though i don't have a problem
vaccine i just like my my my work having
this type of control over me
but i'm gonna end up doing it then my
recommendation is do it tomorrow get it
over with because that gap between that
angst ah that frustration is going to
have
health is going to make you nuts don't
do it it's going to cost you physically
it's going to cost you psychologically
it's cost you emotionally if you're not
going to do it find a new job asap and
move on but be at peace with your
decision and then go on it's that gap of
that rage that anger that i'm fighting i
am yelling i am cussing at the radio i'm
angry with around my kids
it's this gap
make your decision be at peace with it
and now i've got to go
now that i've made this decision
i'm going to go be about what's next
and that's what you can control what you
can't control is here's what my boss
said i'm going to do here's what my
county said i'm going to do you can't
control those things you can only
control you and the
the
mental health piece the relational piece
the psychological piece of spiritual
piece is in that gap which is
i can control what i can control i don't
have to be happy with it i'd be
frustrated by it
but i'm not going to give other people
that much power over my sleep over my
marriage over my parenting over my
relationships over my dating life over
my nutrition i'm not going to give them
that kind of power
and i know it's hard man i know people
feel stuck and they feel trapped and
they feel angry that they're being told
that they have to do things i know
people who already got the vaccine
months and months and months ago
but then when their company came out and
said you have to do it they got raged
out just they don't be told what to do
and i totally get that totally get that
and if you already know what you're
going to end up doing anyway then go
ahead and get it done or go ahead and
don't and be at
peace
and then go figure out what's next so
that's just my recommendation but i know
that it's different than tucking your
shirt in let's make it an analogy right
i was just trying to draw a long arc
here
that we have businesses our jobs tell us
to do all kinds of stuff and we have to
decide am i in or am i out
and um those are hard hard things it's
hard when they ask you to fudge numbers
it's hard when they ask you to
come in every saturday for the next five
years we're not going to give you
overtime it's hard when they give you
another department and another
department another department and no
raise it's hard if you work at a
faith-based place and they tell you or a
mission-centric place and they say
oh you want more money oh i
we thought we were just doing this for
um something bigger than us
and you feel bad for trying to
put your value and your worth
financially on the table and say hey i
need some more financial support for all
the extra work i'm doing every business
has these things and this one's gotta
the vaccines become as political third
rails but we make these decisions all
the time
and it's hard and it's annoying and it's
frustrated what i want to do is just
take the air out of it it's just another
decision that somebody put in front of
you i'm gonna do it i'm gonna not and
then i'm gonna be about controlling what
i can control and then i'm gonna move on
and then i'm gonna move on
i'm not gonna give other people that
much power in my life to take my soul
from me but that's it and if you
disagree with me
that is so that is your prerogative and
you can hit the little 15
second button and just pass right past
all of this
except we already passed it that was
kind of awesome all right let's go to
caitlin in colorado springs hey caitlin
what's going on
hi
how are you
um you know hanging in there hanging in
there good deal
yeah all right so how are you hanging in
there how can i help
so my sister is high functioning autism
and she has been in and out of an
abusive relationship for the past three
years how old is she um
she's 27 27 okay um
mentally probably around 18 ish
she just found out that she is pregnant
by this man and he chose his living
girlfriend over her
and so he she has asked me to adopt her
child
and i don't know how to even go about
processing this
whoo
man
wow
welcome to it right
yeah yikes
um so there's a lot here
um
he doesn't have to
be married to her legally but he doesn't
get to opt out of this baby's life right
yeah well i guess if you adopted this
baby you would be taking that
responsibility from him is he signing
over custody
um
it's so he has a child by another
woman and he fought aggressively for
that child and so i'm guessing
it would be a joint custody situation
between
me my husband and him yeah are they
interesting too
yeah so i'm asking some questions i've
got real strong feelings about this but
um
tell me about your sister she's
high-functioning autistic does she have
is she full and like full-time
employment
um no she hasn't held the job for three
years she'll start for two weeks and get
overwhelmed and quit okay is she seeking
any sort of support care
or
no
no okay um
will she or just will she not
she doesn't think there's anything wrong
with her so she refuses to seek any sort
of care even though i know she would be
a candidate for any sort of governmental
support or i mean she needs mental
health support she needs it all but she
refuses to admit it
is this pregnancy
a wake-up call to her or no
no she's pretending it's not happening
other than asking me to adopt a child
i don't often
on this show especially say the words
i've never heard this situation before
but i've never heard this situation
before
um
so
how did the conversation come up with
her coming to you
she called me crying saying
the test is positive so
um more of the situation is that she was
helping watch his daughter even though
his live-in girlfriend was there as well
i didn't fully understand the situation
and then he asked her to
cut the birth control out of her arm
the rod that goes in and so she did
and her doctor specifically told her
you're going to get pregnant because
you're sleeping with him
and then with her with his living
girlfriend in the place
yeah
yeah she doesn't know about any of this
she doesn't know his living girlfriend
lives there
no their living girlfriend doesn't know
about anything with my sisters but
they're sleeping together or any of that
i just have one word awesome
yeah wow
okay and so she calls me surprised but
she's pregnant of course
is she surprised
cognitively like is this a surprise to
her or is she surprised that she got
caught you know what i mean that she got
caught is is her cognitive capacity one
that she doesn't is unable to put
one plus one equals two that if i cut
this
birth control
out of my arm
and i have unprotected sex with this guy
i'm gonna get pregnant is she unable to
make that algorithm work or is she being
an immature
young person and living in denial
i think it's more of the denial
okay
if how old are you
i'm 31 31 okay where's mom in this
situation
uh she's done she's so tired of dealing
with my sister
my dad too yeah
okay um
can she hear
can your sister hear a family
conversation
probably not no
okay
so i'm gonna strongly recommend you do
not adopt this kid
okay
um i have an explanation
do what
do you have an explanation as to why um
it's not your kid
and i say that meaning it's his kid
and there's i've never heard of a joint
custody where he doesn't really want to
have
he doesn't really want to have custody
he doesn't want to be with her but he's
going to work out some joint arrangement
with y'all too i mean that's just how
that works
if you adopt this kid he signs off that
he's out she signs off that she's out
and this is y'all's kid
and then you have a sister with mental
health challenges that are i mean here's
the thing
a hurricane landed in your home and you
all got to deal with it
correct
but sort of because it's her home
and my guess is you all have been
cleaning up this you say your parents
were just tired i heard it in your voice
you it wasn't just words like you they
are exhausted
and they've been dealing with this
forever
and here it is now it's grandkid time
now it's niece or nephew time for you
and
if he came
everybody has to have a grown-up
conversation what's going to happen
and if he was to say i will sign this
child over i don't want this kid i don't
want anything to do with this kid
and she said i'm gonna sign this over
and i'm gonna move in with you guys for
the next seven months and deal with this
then that's another thing
and then maybe you and your husband
are the most altruistic extraordinary
people on the planet you adopt this kid
and she's got some sort of
peripheral relationship but y'all hold
boundaries and it's just going to be a
tough road to hoe for the next 20 years
and that may be a very realistic reality
for you
but there i don't there's no such thing
as a joint custody where you adopt a kid
but dad's involved like there's no
three-way custody kind of thing it's his
baby yeah okay yeah and so what i would
do is call him
do you have a relationship with him can
you talk to him
i have his number i've met him a few
times it'd anger her to no end if i
contacted him without her knowledge well
she's gonna have to be a part of the
conversation too
because the courts are gonna recognize
her as an adult unless she gets unless
you call on her and get a psych
evaluation that says she is unfit
yeah and then they can terminate
parental rights in utero
and then the the second that baby is
born it goes to a family member but
they're gonna have to do a psych work up
on it it's i mean it's world war three
but you're in it right and she's gonna
fight you and hate you and all of those
things
or she may be totally at peace what you
and your husband have to come to terms
with and you and your mom and your dad
have to come to terms with
is
there's a baby here that's caught up in
the middle of this
yeah and you've got your exhaustion with
your sister your anger with your sister
you're we've been telling you her this
for 30 years with your sister
and that's on one side of the equation
the other side is there's a baby here
and my guess is the fact that you're
calling me you're not the kind of person
just to let that ride you know what i
mean
great exactly do you want to adopt this
i i mean i have two of my own and we
were done
and now that there's this infant out
there that didn't do any of this like i
can't just let it go into foster care or
with this dad that is an abusive man
like
i
i have this um
savior complex i think honestly well
there's a savior complex and then
there's that baby needs a home
and those are two different things you
grew up in the home of a sister with
special needs
so
everyone who grows up in the home of a
kid with special needs is either all the
way out or they are looking for people
to help that's just that's that's the
that's the you get to see a ringside
seat to an empathetic life right so
you're there
um
here's the only way i see this thing
playing out you have to sit down with
her and with him
and say she's pregnant we will take this
baby but everybody signs off
okay and
you got to go with an attorney and
through court and get it all documented
out that he doesn't loot back on you and
he probably still will loot back on you
she will loot back on you just know
you're in it
okay and it's gonna be a mess which
means you and your husband have to be
anchored tightly together you have to
know how far you're gonna go on this
deal you're gonna have to make sure
you're talking to a pastor or to
a marriage counselor as y'all walk
through this because your picture of
what your life is gonna be is different
now
yeah and my gut tells me you've always
known something like this was coming
or you've always had in the back of your
head she'll move in with us at some
point or we're gonna have to deal like
you've always had that back there is
that fair
yeah it was something drugs or something
we knew something was gonna happen right
yeah and
that's where we are
and so what this situation desperately
needs is
one or two or three or four strong
adults
who are going to cut through the
she's not like me she's gonna be mad at
me i don't care
now there's a baby involved
my niece or my nephew's involved and
your parents are tired sorry
i get that but we're all in it now
and i know this guy's
a complete and total scumbag but it's
his kid
yeah and if he wants to say this is my
baby
um
he gets to do that legally
and
that's gonna be that's going to be
something you're going to have to grieve
together until you know about abuse and
whatnot then you're going to file on
them and then you'll end up with this
child anyway right
right yep
i think that's what i'm trying to avoid
in the situation too if i can is to not
have to go and rescue those horrible
situations right
i'm so sorry you're in the middle of
this caitlyn
yeah it's rough it's new too fresh you
know yeah how far along is your sister
six weeks
okay six weeks
yeah okay
yeah so you know you've been down the
stroll there's a lot that can happen
between now and
you know
eight and a half months from now nine
months from now yeah um yeah i
definitely can
so here's what i do you live is your
sister live around joe
about an hour away okay is she open to
coffee meetings is she open to
dinner with you once a week or something
like that or is that impossible
no she is yeah she's really involved in
my kid's life like she's great as a
nanny and a babysitter just not as a
parent okay she's very involved in our
lives
so it sounds like
high functioning and really smart and is
really loving and can turn it down when
it is convenient is that fair or is that
is that yeah am i not being
kind
no that's true she can um it's just when
she decides to and if she doesn't allow
the consistent
i don't i don't really know how to
describe it like if you see a
non-high-functioning autism person like
rocking in the corners that's kind of
what happens in her mind when she gets
overwhelmed by a decision okay she just
can't settle
okay
and
when you walk alongside her is she able
to stay anchored a little bit
a little okay but then she also needs
someone to tell her what needs to happen
okay
that's where i was actually aiming which
is you and your husband sit down and say
what are our boundaries here how far
will we go what will we do
and that will be everything from will
she move in with us when she's three
months pregnant and for the next six
months or will we financially support
this this pregnancy or
um and her nutrition and her are you
gonna go with her on her um
ob gyn business i mean how far are we
gonna go here
and make sure you all write that down we
are on the same page you and me and give
each other permission to shift he may
come to you a couple weeks from now and
say i just can't do it or come to you a
few weeks from now and say we're gonna
we're gonna go to hell and back to get
this kid right whatever that i mean
y'all may change as you go right
and then make sh write down
how you're going to support and love her
not fix it and solve this problem this
problem is is i mean this is what this
is
but letting her know
i'm going to love you through this and
handing her a sheet of paper that says
here's how i'm going to support you i'm
going gonna come to your doctor visits
you're welcome at my house at any time
if i'm gonna adopt this baby this is
what this will look like
if i see that you're doing drugs i'm
gonna call the police i'm gonna call
child protective services
immediately and that may freak her out
but i want her to hold a piece of paper
and it says to hear and maybe the title
of it is here's how big sister is going
to love you
yeah okay and you've been through two of
these and make sure that you know i mean
it can set up as a very caring next step
um
and be really direct with her about i
know that we all both know that when
things get hard
um
you shut down and so i want here's
here's our when we start to shut down
here's what we're gonna do and i'm gonna
be there for you or i'm not gonna be
there for whatever your boundaries are
and then you need to let her know that
we're gonna have to if you want me to
adopt this baby and again she may have
just found out and freaked out and told
you that and then
a month from now she's going to want to
raise this kid so the option to bait to
adopt this child may be zero maybe none
you never know right
um but it's boundaries direct
conversation and all of this ends up
with a conversation with the four of you
him her and you and your husband if this
adoption's gonna actually go through
that baby's lucky to have you your
sister's lucky to have you and i know
that loving and being connected to
somebody who has
cognitive challenges who has atypical
um
learning challenges who's autistic who
has any number of challenges i know it's
hard and it's exhausting and so thank
you for loving her even when it's so so
so hard
um there is no when it comes to adoption
there is no
hey we'll all just figure this out live
nope
there's got to be lawyers involved
there's got to be clear things involved
there's got to be boundaries and
protections for this kid otherwise this
kid becomes a pawn in a long game and
the kid pays
price thank you for your heart thank you
for your connection here we'll be right
back on the dr john dolone show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john delony show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do cause i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we're back let's go to kate in
phoenix hey kate what's going on
hey john i'm doing well how about
yourself rocking on dude till the break
it on what's up
thanks for taking my calls and honor to
speak with you and i'm a huge fan of
your shows yes did you know hey we're up
to 22. that's awesome
thank you for being on in our gang
thank you
so my husband and i have been dealing
with unexplained infertility for about
two years now and we're debating and
telling my mom or keeping it private
from my family the reason being is my
mom hasn't been a safe place for me in
the past and i've always had to set
strong boundaries but recently almost
every time i see her she's been making
really passive aggressive statements
about babies and i don't know how to
handle it or how to tell her to stop
without telling her
about our journey so i'd love your
advice on whether or not to tell my mom
about this vulnerable topic as i'm
scared of her opinions and comments that
will come with it
cali
number one man i've walked that journey
and
i know that's haunting i'm sorry
and it's scary and debilitating and it's
identity it's a mess and i'm sorry did
you learn that
man and then you top it off with the one
woman that you want to be able to lean
on is not safe right what does that mean
when you say she's not safe
um
just to give a brief context like she
was raised in a pretty toxic family
environment and then hold on hold on
hold on hold on you're defending here
yeah so i'm going to say something rude
i don't care how she grew up why is she
unsafe for you
um she's really controlling um what is
that
um just growing up because she didn't
have a lot of control in her life she
always would you know tell me what to
wear what to do what i needed in my life
and
like if something's wrong she would just
be like all right well abc you're not
fixing it because of this and it just
gets so personal with my body on this
topic
um that i'm just scared she's gonna give
you know ask really hard questions about
like tests or examinations or give me
just an opinion in my marriage and
that's just a place i don't want to
invite her in even if i say when you say
like invite like she's going to ask you
about
infertility treatment she's going to ask
you about your sex life she's going to
ask what are you what are you afraid
she's going to get into
i'm i'm scared that i'm gonna have to
answer some questions that she might ask
and then the other side is i'm scared
she's gonna tell everyone that that she
knows because that's kind of what she
does
she copes with telling her friends about
my personal life and my family and i
just don't
yeah i don't want everyone involved in
this
so your mom does not deserve the level
of power she has in your life
correct
and she may have never hit you but
you're in an abusive relationship that
and you've you've drawn boundaries
before how old are you
31 how long have you been married
uh five years okay it's time your mom
gets out of your marriage
because she's parenting your husband now
too
and she's parenting your unborn kids now
too and it's time for her to be done
a couple of things you can do here
number one i want to back out and put
mom aside
this is your body this is your marriage
this is your journey
but i want to tell you that infertility
is nothing to be ashamed of
okay you didn't screw something up
this isn't a fault issue this isn't a
failure issue
okay
and the shame that comes with this and
the identity challenges that come with
this stack up on the stories your mom
told you
your whole life right
yeah
you didn't fail anything
and often secrets literally become
inflammatory responses maybe our bodies
respond to secrets and to head
controlling messages
and trying to control everything around
us and when we try to control who's
saying what about what and who knows
what about what who do you suddenly
sound like
yeah who
her yep
and so often one of the most
extraordinary responses to growing up in
that world is complete and utter
vulnerability
i'm an open book because i got nothing
to hide because i'm awesome
not in a yolo millennial way like yeah
bro i'm awesome not like that
but i'm worth being loved
and my body is my body whether it's
doing what i wanted to or not and my
husband's body is my husband's body
whether he you know i mean
we are standing up on our own two feet
we are standing as tall as we can and
this is our journey
and what i found in my life when i
become obsessive about trying to control
messaging
when i become obsessive about who knows
what and how and who got what story and
i told these people this part of it but
i told them all of it and this person
knows how i really feel
i'm the one who goes bonkers
in my
spiritual life my psychological life my
physical life pays the pays the price
so what i would tell you is i don't care
what anybody says this is y'all's
marriage y'all's bodies meow's journey
to walk and the people who love you will
walk it with you and the people who want
to judge it or criticize it are welcome
to leave the building
when that comes to your i'm going to
tell you my thought here and i'm going
to caveat it with i am not a woman
i have i've been in a relationship where
we struggled infertility but i know it's
different so i am i am prefacing it with
that okay
i also am prefacing it with
my parents are
um
extr were extraordinary in this and so i
didn't have your situation okay
i know the psychology of secrets
is poison
it kills us
i also know the psychology of trying to
live under somebody else's control
is poison
it's one of the things that sets off our
anxiety alarms out of depression
is feeling like i'm immobile
and so my recommendation here is
you call your mom and you'll meet in
person and you tell her all of it
and also tell her i am not inviting you
to tell me about what tests i should get
i'm not inviting you into my sex life
i'm not inviting you into my marriage i
am telling you that this is the journey
i don't want to hear any more jokes i
don't hear any more comments about it
we are walking alongside this we've got
doctors we've got friends we've got a
counselor we've got whoever
and
this is where we are
period at the end of the story
and if you can set that type of boundary
it will come with her trying to ramrod
that boundary over
and that's when you find out how strong
kate is
right
yeah
and when she bams up against that
boundary and you hold firm
suddenly there's this huh
and you stand up a little bit taller and
a little bit taller and you realize i'm
way stronger than i thought
and then she'll bam up against it again
and it will
hurt less
does that make sense
yeah that's convoluted
and if you just want to leave mom
completely out of this leave mom
completely out of this that's up to you
too
and when she gets to make her in her
little comments she doesn't get a vote
in your life
she doesn't get a vote so she can make
every stupid little comment she's like i
just wish i had a grandkid
well i wish i had a mom that was an
idiot and well neither of us get what we
want right
you know what i mean
yeah
have you ever um gone to talk to
somebody have you and your husband
talked about her role in y'all's
marriage
yeah
i we went through some marriage
counseling and that ended up being the
biggest topic that i ended up staying
behind and doing this on therapy through
okay
so is this your first big test yeah this
one's a pretty big one
um of just like i think it's just my
emotions are so attached to this one
like in other situations i was able to
hard block but
it feels probably the most vulnerable i
felt in a really long time and i think
i'm just scared of
like opening that piece to her and
learning how to block her in the end
often when we build walls they don't
protect us from people on the outside
they keep us locked up
and they keep you from living wide open
and walls and boundaries are different i
think
um
sometimes especially in abusive
relationships man walls keep us alive
and we have to have them like i can't
see them i can't hear them i will not
talk to them i get those boundaries are
critically important
but when i'm 31 either i'm just going to
say you know i'm not talking to my mom
anymore like i was like i'm not going to
take these coffee meetings anymore like
she has lost her role in my life
or
i'll see you on thanksgiving and i will
be there for four hours and then i'm
gonna leave i'm gonna stay in hotel and
then we're gonna go home right there's
those kind of boundaries and those are
important and they're critical and they
keep everybody safe and she can complain
all she wants this is your life
the other side of it is there's some
really extraordinary power
and strength in saying this is my body
and i'm not ashamed of it i'm sad and
frustrated by me and my husband's
situation and again i keep saying
everybody i know
i'm not insinuating this is your fault
right um i'm saying or that this is in
any way
your issue i'm saying
i want you to take full ownership of
kate and
your mom still has a piece of cake still
right
yeah
that's really good advice i i'm
definitely gonna take that to heart and
do you feel scared when i said yeah sit
down and just tell her and then say and
i'm not want to hear any of these five
things cause you can't do one without
the other kate you can't say yeah hey
this is happening and then she's gonna
she's gonna do exactly what you know
she's gonna do and then you're gonna be
mad at her
yeah it's this powerful i am 30 freaking
one i'm not going to hear you talk about
my husband period i'm not going to hear
you i know how to go get a doctor's
appointment i don't need your help you
know what i mean
yeah
oh yeah i do want to do it i do want to
meet with her i think i just i'm going
to have to just mentally prepare myself
just to how to have those boundaries and
vulnerability which i think often times
i'm one of those flight i just want to
run away from it but just learning to
sit in it and be okay with just being
firm in who i am so i think it's a
really good challenge
and to please don't do this blind
meaning
have a counseling appointment already
set up
have a appointment with two of your
women in your life who are mentors to
you have a have a
a dinner set up with two of your closest
friends that you're gonna go directly to
or some time with your husband you're
gonna go direct like don't just do this
blind
right
you can't just say like yeah i'm gonna
get in the ring and fight that guy you
need to train for the fight you know you
need dreams to fight and you need to
have an appointment with a doctor after
it because you're probably gonna get hit
um but there is some extraordinary power
in this vulnerability
the other thing about vulnerability is
you can get hurt real bad
right
yeah the beauty here i feel like is a i
let me be honest with you i'm trying to
sound like i'm all smart
when you called and i heard you i heard
in your voice a daughter who wants to
tell her mom yeah
and that also means there's a daughter
who's still holding on to a fantasy that
this is going to be the time when it all
changes and it might not it probably
won't
and yet
you want to tell your mom you don't want
to keep holding these secrets and the
secrets are just poisoning you and
that's when i'm going to tell you
because i'm not ashamed
this is our reality this is our story
right now and i do not need your help
and so it's no more secrets plus
boundaries and usually we get those
things we do one or the other we have
these real tight secrets or we have
these wild boundaries and i want to push
people more towards the middle it's both
which means i'm going to have strength
and it's going to hurt really bad i'm
going to find stronger footing and
deeper relationships with people i love
and i'm going to get my heart broken
because i wish so badly my mom would
come through and she's just not going to
and every time i'm in these
conversations it always surprises me
but your mom will break down and start
weeping and say i've been there too and
you didn't even know it right
probably not but possibly
but to anyone listening to this who's
struggling with infertility
man
don't be ashamed
you didn't fail you're not broken
you do something wrong
this is your story it's heartbreaking it
can be frustrating especially out a
picture of a family that's what it's
going to look like and here's our
timeline and all of a sudden the world
built you a different set of cards
just know that the secrets hurt nobody
but you
and if people are going to show
themselves their true colors when you
say here's the hurt that me and my
family are going through right now me
and my partner are going through right
now and they show their true colors by
giving you stupid advice or
saying well haven't you done this but
then
you can grieve that relationship because
that one's over
you can have some peace and move on
you can uh dust your sandals off dust
your shoulders off and move on i know
that's easier said than done but
thank you so much for that call kate oh
that one's hard um all right hey real
quick um i got this email let's see here
it's right here
um
nettie
she wrote in and said i recently heard
you talk about a woman that married a
man who had a gambling addiction just
like her father
you said people often marry their
unfinished business can you explain what
you mean by that
yes
when we don't get things as kids
we often go
we often try to solve that problem
relationally you always hear me say kids
feel a gap between them and their
parents especially when their parents
have mental health challenges when their
parents have addiction challenges they
have physical
challenges
kids know
i should be connected to my dad or to my
mom and i'm not connected so i divorce
is so hard on kids
and they say
i must be the problem and they go about
trying to solve it
lori gottlieb she's a phenomenal writer
and um mental health practitioner she's
got a great podcast too um
she says that i love what she says she
says we have a radar for the familiar
even if it's painful
or hurtful
our brains always try and solve for the
familiar and they're always trying to
solve these recurring gaps and so
we can think that we want different we
can think that we want unique or we want
adventurous but the most powerful body
parts of our brains and our bodies
search desperately for the familiar so
here's how this plays out a lot
your dad let's say he was a loud yeller
he yelled a lot that's how he got power
in the house slamming doors yelling and
all that stuff or he was obsessed with
um always leaving the house he was
always going to do this thing or do that
thing or his garden like this is my
garden right or hunting or whatever the
thing is
and you said in your head
i'm never gonna marry a guy like that
ever
and then you meet dan and dan's quiet
and laid back and he could care less
about baseball or hunting he's actually
a gamer
right
and you told yourself you were never
going to marry someone who's always gone
always running around always you know on
weekend trips or whatever obsessed with
baseball
so you married dan
he never leaves your house physically
but he's never there emotionally
psychologically spiritually because he's
down in the basement playing video games
and then what you do
is you have one model for how to solve
relationship challenges that solve that
disconnection you do whatever your mom
did or whatever the other adult in your
house did
and you use the same words the same
wooing techniques
shame the same one up one down
positioning all those things
and then all of a sudden this same dance
has started he may not be off hunting
but he's off in
call of duty
and then you respond in the same way
your mom or your dad did and it creates
the exact same dynamic and suddenly
you're married to a guy who disappears
on you again
and he may not yell but he controls the
house by being really quiet and pouting
or over time he may get louder and
louder because you're responding in ways
that
make
him want to respond and then also you're
in this dance
and kids are always asking what did i do
to make dad want to ignore me to make
mom call me fat what did i do to make my
mom yell or to slam the cabinets or to
make my dad want to leave
and kids i'll tell you nothing when
parents do that that's on them that's
their challenges that they're working
through their heartaches and their heart
their their their struggles
and so
i say we always marry our unfinished
business
your brain's always looking for familiar
so when you're in a place where you say
i think i'm gonna marry this person i
think i love this person or you've been
married for five or ten years and you
think
man i
my alarms go off every time this happens
or that happens
just pause and back up
go 30 000 feet away from where your
heart's not racing anymore and say
how's this connected to what i saw when
i was a kid and often it made this
search situation maybe it may not be it
may not be
gambling it may be alcohol it may not be
alcohol but it may be i married a
workaholic it may be this or that
and suddenly you're gonna find out oh my
gosh i married my mom oh my gosh i made
my dad
oh my gosh i married somebody just like
my dad except completely opposite
and that doesn't mean you're broke and
doesn't mean you're it means you
you now have a context for how to move
forward and reconnect to reimagine your
relationship and build something new and
wonderful
um but that's what it means when you say
we solve our we marry our unfinished
business
do you all have you all ever done that
we got people with that going no i'm
gonna talk about you absolutely yes yeah
that's a difficult question i'd have to
think about it yeah my i mean my husband
is very similar to my dad but in good
ways yeah but i mean yeah very much so
zach
okay
just
oh that's so great all right as you wrap
up today's show
cool man tough i think it's 1992 dr
feelgood album it's the crew for me and
kelly
this isn't a greatest song's ever
written it's called don't go away mad
just go away we could sail away or catch
a freight train or a rocket ship into
outer space there's nothing left to do
too many things were said to ever make
it feel like yesterday did seasons must
change separate paths separate ways if
we blame it on anything let's blame it
on the on the rain
i knew it all along i'd have to write
this song we were too young to fall in
love i guess i knew it all along
that's all right that's okay
we were walking through some youth
smiling through some pain that's all
right that's okay let's turn the page
and remember what i say girl and it goes
this way
girl don't go away mad
girl just go away right here on the dr
john dolone show
[Music]